(whoosh)
(mouse clicks)
(electronic beeping)
- Raphael Pelayo from Stanford University.
Dr. Pelayo is a professor of
psychiatry and sleep medicine,
and he's here to tell us all
about sleep in this population.
Dr. Pelayo.
Yay.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Are they clapping louder
in that overflow room?
Do you guys know, anybody know?
What's happening over there?
Good morning.
I'm Raphael Pelayo.
I'm a sleep doctor at Stanford,
and thank you so much for the invitation.
Really happy to be here.
You guys can come on in.
I am a professor now in the
department of psychiatry,
but I'm not a psychiatrist.
I wanted to be a psychiatrist
when I was in high school and college,
but I ended up, when I
got to medical school,
switching to neurology, and I
switched to child neurology,
just as a pathway to get into sleep.
My interest has always...
Since the first week of medical school,
I started hanging around the sleep lab,
and that's what I've been doing.
And I wanna talk to you
guys a little bit about,
see but everybody sleeps.
You know, when I walked in this morning,
I saw the overflow room, so
say hi to you guys over there,
and it was packed.
It was packed, there was
nowhere to sit over there.
And I think, wow, this
room must really be full.
And I walked in here, and I said, whoa,
what are these empty seats over here now?
So our overflow friends
could come over here
if they wanted to, right?
I teach a class on campus
called Sleep and Dreams,
set up by Dr. William Dement in 1970.
And Dr. Dement is now retired,
so I get to teach the class.
And yesterday, no, Wednesday
was our last day of class,
we've got finals this week.
But one of the things
that happens in our class
is if you fall asleep
during one of our lectures,
we will squirt you with water.
(audience laughs)
With a water gun, and
you get bonus points.
You actually can get bonus points
for falling asleep in class.
So, I didn't bring my water gun with me,
but it brings up that should
somebody fall asleep in class,
and it turned out that when I did the math
when I took over the course,
that if you fell asleep
at every single class,
you could end up with a C.
So we had to stop doing that,
we had to cap the bonus points.
(audience laughs)
I have disclosure.
I did consulting with a
couple different companies
and they're listed there.
None of these are gonna be relevant
to our talk today, I believe,
but if something comes up, I'll flag it.
But I don't think any of
these will be relevant to it.
We're gonna talk about
overall sleep disorders.
I mentioned I trained in child neurology,
but I mostly took care of adult patients.
And what I actually do is what I think of
as more like family sleep medicine.
'Cause if one person doesn't sleep,
it affects the entire family.
It's unusual to have just
one person sleep poorly
and everybody else is like, it's okay.
It affects everybody in the family
if someone doesn't sleep well.
And also these sleep
disorders are familial.
I'll show you a few of them.
But sleep disorders are familial.
So if you see a child with sleep problems,
you're gonna find parents
with sleep problems.
And if you see an adult
with sleep problems,
you should ask about their
kids, their relatives.
Almost all of the sleep disorders
that we're gonna address
today are familial.
So what do we see in clinic?
These are the typical conditions we see.
We have a little bit less than an hour
to talk to you about these.
Each one of these can be
a lecture unto itself.
We'll have a Q&A afterwards.
Insomnia.
Short of falling asleep or staying asleep
(mumbles) the next day,
it's probably one of
the more common things
that you'll deal with
with adults and children
with disabilities.
Sleep apnea, I would say it's like fog,
it gets into everything,
you gotta take care of it,
it's like sand on the beach.
If you don't take care of the sleep apnea,
it's hard to take care of
these other things you'll have.
And many times you'll encounter patients
who have tried some type
of behavioral treatment
or stress and medication
to help their sleep,
and they say it didn't work.
And the reason it didn't work was
there was an underlying
sleep apnea condition
that hadn't been addressed.
So you gotta clean that up
first, and then you can retry
things that supposedly
have failed in the past.
Now you may find that they do work.
Parasomnias are things
that go bump in the night.
If I give a talk at a
high school or college,
parasomnias are what the
kids wanna talk about.
They wanna talk about lucid dreaming,
they wanna talk about sleep paralysis,
they wanna talk about sleepwalking.
Those are things that interest them.
Restless leg syndrome,
extremely common condition.
Somebody in this room must have it,
it's impossible to have
this many people in the room
and nobody have restless leg syndrome.
Some of you must have restless legs.
Yes, thank you, a couple of
people raised their hands.
You were one of the
speakers, weren't you, no?
Hi.
(audience laughs)
That explains a lot.
I see you kind of moving around and stuff,
I was watching you.
I see, got it, okay.
We thought it was just energy.
Restless legs runs in families.
And I'll tell you my youngest case,
well, restless legs,
first of all I should describe it to you.
It's an unpleasant
sensation, hard to describe,
with an urge to move,
characterized by an urge to move.
First described over 600 years ago by Sir,
I forgot his first name, Sir Willis,
the guy who did the Circle of Willis.
That same guy described
restless leg syndrome
as a neurological condition.
Before then it was thought to be a curse.
And it feels like a
curse to a lot of people,
because it's a condition
where it only bothers you
when you stop working.
As long as you're moving
around, it doesn't bother you.
When you sit still, it'll come on.
And I can tell you, my
youngest case that I saw
was a two-year-old girl
adopted from China.
And restless legs is tied
in to iron metabolism.
And these wonderful parents, I mean,
I don't have tell you how
generous somebody must be
to adopt a child, right?
Amazing heart these people
have to adopt a child.
And they adopted this
little girl from China,
and they said that she doesn't sleep well.
And obviously people said,
well did you try sleeping with her,
is it neglect, is she just stressed out?
The parents said, no,
we'll sleep with her.
And a common question,
something you can think
about yourself when you interact with,
especially with younger children,
if they have poor sleep, you can ask,
does the problem get better
or worse or stay the same
if they sleep with the
parents or their caretakers?
And usually, if it's a behavioral issue,
if they sleep with the
parents, it gets better.
Little kids usually wanna be with people
that love them and protect them.
But this little girl slept just
as poorly with the parents,
the adoptive parents.
In fact, they said, we
wish she'd sleep with us.
It was an Asian family,
they said we'd like to sleep with her,
it's in our culture,
but we can't sleep with
her, she moves too much.
So I said, you know,
there's not many other things it could be
to differentiate a diagnosis,
so I said let's just give
her a little bit of iron.
Let's just see if she has,
we measured her ferritin,
and it turns out that
she has restless legs.
And the parents said she
got much better quickly
after we treated her.
I think we gave her a
low dose of pramipexole,
which we can talk about
later, a medication.
But the interesting thing is
when she learned to speak English,
her first word in English was "itchy".
'Cause she would say "itchy",
she knew what she had.
So restless legs is
something to think about.
And when you see it in a kid,
always ask about the parents.
And you have to always ask that
kind of semi-awkward question
to whoever brings them in,
the mother, are you the birth mother?
Because restless legs typically
flares during pregnancy.
And you'll meet women who'll tell you
that they know they're pregnant,
they know to check for pregnancy,
because they start feeling the legs,
the legs start bothering them.
That's restless legs.
Delayed sleep phase syndrome,
second most common sleep disorder
among young adults and
teenagers, the most common simply
being behaviorally induced
insufficient sleep syndrome.
People who just don't get enough sleep
for their own reasons.
Which is very weird, by the way.
Animals don't do that.
Animals don't just stay awake
for the fun of it usually.
Usually they sleep on a rhythm.
But delayed sleep phase syndrome,
characterized by difficulty falling asleep
rather than staying asleep.
If you've never made a diagnosis,
it's because you've missed it.
It's just that common.
Look it up, learn it, you're
gonna start seeing it.
Delayed sleep phase syndrome,
characterized by
difficulty falling asleep,
not staying asleep.
Most of the time you talk
with an adult with insomnia
or sleep problems, they say things like,
"Doc, I have no trouble falling asleep,
"I have trouble staying asleep."
This is the opposite.
"I have trouble falling asleep,
"but once I fall asleep, I'm just fine."
Interestingly, delayed
sleep phase syndrome
was first described in 1981,
at Montefiore Hospital, New York City,
where I trained a few years later.
And it was described among
a group of young adults
who had what was called at
that point atypical depression.
What was atypical about
their depression was
the insomnia pattern was different.
They had trouble falling
asleep, not staying asleep,
and didn't have the other
feature sometimes of depression
called terminal insomnia,
which is a bad term,
terminal insomnia, which means insomnia
at the early morning hours.
But the other thing
about these individuals,
these young individuals,
was that they did not
respond to medication.
None of the antidepressants at the time
seemed to make any difference to them.
Once it was identified as
a circadian sleep disorder,
and it was the first circadian
sleep disorder identified,
they reset their sleep schedules,
and once that happened,
their sleep normalized,
and they felt better
and their mood improved.
I'm always happy to come to this meeting,
and I mentioned it to you earlier,
when I was a medical student,
I got to do a project
on delayed sleep phase syndrome.
And it wasn't that good a project,
but I wrote my project
on it and submitted it
to the Journal of Pediatrics.
And the letter of rejection
was signed by Lucy Crain,
so I was very proud of her.
(audience laughs)
So when I saw her...
And it wasn't really rejected,
it was like, this needs more
work, and she was right.
But I was a fourth-year medical student,
and it was before the Bell Commission,
so I had a 110-hour workweek.
So I just never got to it.
So it always bothered
me that I didn't do it,
but then I reconciled it.
I'm 56 now, I was 25
years old at the time,
so I'm okay with it now.
(audience laughs)
But it was a good thing,
I think it was a good rejection.
It pointed me in the right
direction where I have to be.
(indistinct question from audience)
Yeah, much more, no, no, you
are thanked with gratitude,
because it helped me think
about how I want to do things,
and how it goes.
But anyway, that's delayed
sleep phase syndrome.
So learn that condition.
"My child won't sleep, my child is tired."
Wouldn't it be nice if
we could have kids sleep
whenever we wanted to?
(audience laughs)
Wouldn't that be so cool, right?
Can you imagine if you could have them
fall asleep on demand?
You can feed them whenever you want,
why can't you make them
sleep whenever you want?
Why can't we do that?
Parents would love it.
When you travel,
wouldn't it be convenient
if you could make them sleep
whenever you wanted to?
(audience laughs)
And actually this is one of
the reasons kids get medicated,
is because it's inconvenient
when they're awake.
So a lot of times when some--
(audience laughs)
It's true.
Wouldn't you like them to
sleep when you wanted to?
It'd be nice.
And that's why people will
give their kids medication.
So what goes through your
mind when you hear this?
How do you go through this?
So we're gonna touch on
some of these issues.
And one of the things
that's nice about sleep
is that principles of sleep medicine
apply equally to children and adults.
They really do apply across the board.
And the same concepts
that I use with adults
apply to children, and that
goes in both directions.
And we can talk some more as we go along.
Your life is reflected in your sleep,
you sleep's a reflection of your life.
That's our symbol in sleep medicine,
that ying and yang symbol.
That's our official symbol,
that's what I keep on my work ID.
You see, I have it here.
Have a little, if you can see it up front.
See, that's what I keep on my thing.
In sleep medicine early on
they knew they couldn't separate
the mind from the brain.
It kind of goes together.
The day and the night, they're
just part of the whole thing.
So because that's our
symbol, it's a platitude,
but I sort of say this routinely
when I give lectures to my students.
Your life's reflected in your sleep,
your sleep's a reflection of your life.
And then what turned out to happen was
that got picked up by,
one of the students put it on a blog
and it got picked up by another blog.
And that was carried on.
And now, I was at a conference in Houston,
and some lady walked over to me,
says I quoted you in a talk,
says that's one of the most
famous sleep quotes out there, she said.
So if you look up my name and quotes,
this shows up along with the Dalai Lama
and Benjamin Franklin as a sleep quote.
It's ridiculous.
(audience laughs)
I'm not kidding, just look it up.
Some of you are just browsing the internet
as I speak anyway.
Probably in that overflow room
that's what they're doing.
(audience laughs)
But one time somebody
showed up with a picture
of a mattress store in Lebanon.
And there was that quote
with my name beneath it
in this mattress store in Lebanon.
(audience laughs)
Just use it, just take
it, you can have it.
But that's a true quote.
And that's the power of our students,
the power of the echo
chamber of the internet,
how that carries on.
The other phrase that I like to say
is that your sleep is biological,
but the way you sleep is learned.
You've all been taught how to sleep.
Whenever you're in track
with anybody's sleep,
all sleep problems have
four components to them.
Child or adult,
all sleep problems have
four components to them.
When you get your history,
you wanna think about the amount of sleep,
the quality of their sleep,
the timing of their sleep,
and what do you think
the fourth one is, guys?
Their state of mind.
Get a sense from your patient,
from whoever you're dealing with,
are they looking forward to sleeping?
Or are they looking
forward to being awake?
Does it matter to them
if they make it on time
to their day program or not?
They may not care.
Sometimes the concerns are
more of their caretakers
than are the actual patient
that they get up on time.
Do you look forward to sleeping?
People with sleep problems
talk a certain way
that nobody else talks.
They say things like,
"I try to go to sleep."
Nobody else talks that way.
Everybody says I go to sleep.
They say I try to sleep.
"If I'm lucky, I'll get
six hours of sleep."
And they imply luck like
it's an external thing,
like sleep is out of their control.
And when you start thinking that way,
you know there's a problem.
So you've gotta get a sense
from anybody you're talking to,
are they looking forward to sleeping?
When you deal with young adults
or especially with teenagers,
ask them who goes to sleep
first, you or your parents?
You'd be surprised how many teenagers
stay awake past their parents.
They may go to their bedrooms
much earlier than their parents.
And the kids do something
that's very un-adult-like.
They convert their bedrooms
to mini studio apartments.
And they hang out in their room.
So when you talk with them, get a sense,
do you spend more hours awake
than sleeping in your bedroom?
You think that's not a good thing to do
if you're spending too much
time awake in the bedroom,
but a lot of kids will do that.
And then the kids will start
sleeping in on weekends.
The first evidence of poor sleep
is sleeping in on weekends.
That's a very un-adult
thing that they'll do.
You may as an adult sleep
in one or two hours.
You don't sleep in five or six hours
typically on Friday compared to Saturday.
The weekend is an artificial thing.
Seven- and eight-year-olds don't sleep in.
Parents wish they would, but they don't.
(audience laughs)
Right?
They don't.
They don't have to, their sleep-satiated.
They're sleep deprived, and
that's why they're sleeping in.
And parents say, poor
kid, it's good for him
to catch up on his sleep.
We don't do that with food, do we?
We don't say, hey, we're gonna starve you
Monday through Friday.
(audience laughs)
Saturday and Sunday, eat all you like,
because I'm starving you
again starting Monday.
(audience laughs)
We don't do that.
But that's what happens with our kids.
The need for sleep is biological,
the way you sleep is learned.
Just know this with adults.
All of you, the first night
you spend with your loved one,
that person you love,
your significant other,
the first night you're with that person,
you got on one side of the bed,
that person took the
other side of the bed.
It was never discussed again after that.
That was your side,
and that was your side.
And when you travel, that's your side,
that's the other person's side.
You never ever change
sides again, I've learned,
until much later in life.
Older folks will have an agreement
that one of them sleeps
closer to the bathroom.
So if they're in a hotel
and the room is rearranged,
that's the only time they
change sides of the bed,
'cause they don't wanna
walk around things.
Other than that, that's
your side of the bed.
And if you don't believe
me that sleep is learned
and you sleep alone,
simply rotate your body
and put your feet where your pillow goes
and see how you feel.
You may fall out of bed if you do that.
Same room, same everything.
(audience laughs)
So sleeping is a learned behavior.
We teach kids how to sleep.
We teach them where
they're gonna be sleeping.
That's an important thing.
Talk to little kids, they'll talk to you
about where they're gonna
sleep, what's gonna happen.
Little kids know, in the dark,
they know which side of the bed mom's on
and which side of the bed dad's on.
They know.
If you speak with a mom,
says my kid comes in
and wakes me up at night.
And I'm like, well why
don't they wake up dad?
Oh, 'cause dad ignores them.
And I'm like, well maybe that's
the problem, then, right?
(audience laughs)
That's the issue.
Why does the kid go to your
side and not the dad's side?
What's going on?
He knows he can sneak in on
my side, not on dad's side.
I figured this out, too.
Corollary to this, what wakes you up
may not be what's keeping you awake.
There's too many sleep disorders,
sleeping is just something
that we all do so much of.
You should not assume
that what's waking you up
is keeping you awake.
You may wake up because you
have a little bit of sleep apnea
and that wakes you up,
or you may wake up because you
have a little bit of reflux.
Ton of reflux in our patient population.
That will wake you up.
But staying awake is something different.
What's keeping you awake?
You're concerned about
things, worried about things.
So you always gotta think in
sense of people's state of mind
and what's waking them up.
We always talk about these sleep stages,
and there's a few things I'd
like to point out to you.
First of all, John's in the back.
Is it John?
Thank you, John cleaned up my slides.
I've had a problem with
this slide for a long time,
and he fixed it for me very
quickly, so thank you, John.
He made these graphics pop, thank you.
(audience applauds)
What he changed was,
we used to talk about,
sleep is divided into,
well, take a step back.
Our entire lives, you've
either been awake,
you've been dreaming, or
sleeping but not dreaming.
That's all we do.
You're awake, you're dreaming,
or sleeping but not dreaming.
And those are the three states
the brain seems to function in.
So we talk about awake,
dreaming sleep, you may know
is equated with rapid eye
movement sleep, REM sleep.
REM sleep, the term was
coined by Dr. William Dement.
Dr. Dement is alive,
he wants people to know
he's still alive, he's 90 years old.
And if you ever wanna visit him,
he's open to visitors.
Just come on down to the campus.
He's real happy to talk to you.
He's around.
He's a great guy.
But anyway, he was into dreaming.
Coming out of World War II,
the big rage in psychiatry
was Freud and psychoanalysis.
He was interested in dreaming.
So he talked about rapid
eye movement sleep,
and he didn't wanna,
he was a two-finger typist,
so he called it R-E-M,
that's how that happened.
(audience laughs)
And then, since he was
interested in dreaming,
he called everything else non-REM, NREM,
kind of disrespectful
to the rest of sleep.
But that's how it turned out.
So we talk about awake,
REM, and non-REM sleep.
And non-REM sleep we divide into
a light, intermediate,
or deeper state of sleep.
The deep sleep is also
called slow-wave sleep.
People often talk to you
about slow-wave sleep.
And slow-wave sleep used to be divided
into stages three and four.
Stage four got dropped as a term.
That's one of the things
that got cleaned up.
Now we just talk about stage three.
I wanna describe to you
how we think of sleep
as light, deep, light and deep sleep.
And talk about REM sleep.
But the people you talk to, your patients,
your patients' families,
they may use the terms
differently than you.
A lot of people equate
deep sleep with dreaming.
That's how they think of it.
And dreaming sleep is one
thing, and delta sleep,
or slow-wave sleep, deep
sleep is something different.
Slow-wave sleep, deep sleep,
maybe 10% of the night.
That's when growth
hormone secretion occurs,
when physical growth occurs.
And deep sleep is, delta sleep, excuse me,
is our deepest sleep,
that's when it's hardest
to wake somebody up.
Underwriter's Laboratories
have measured this.
In deep sleep and delta sleep
you cannot wake up a teenager.
They'll sleep through the smoke alarm.
You cannot count on them.
So whoever you're taking
care of during your lives,
if they're in deep sleep, delta sleep,
you cannot count on them
waking up on their own.
Deep sleep dominates the
first third of the night.
And also there are
certain sleep conditions
that occur at that point,
most of the parasomnias, things
that go bump in the night,
the things that we talk about
with young adults and children
as far as parasomnias, like sleepwalking,
confusional arousal, sleep terrors,
those things occur in the
first third of the night.
And parents say they
can kind of measure it.
If you think somebody's
having sleep terrors
in the last third of the night,
it's more likely to be a
partial complex seizure
than an actual true parasomnia.
And that's a differential
diagnosis to keep in mind.
And you can have both,
you can have seizures and sleep
terrors in the same person.
But the timing kind of
predicts how they're gonna be.
So that's slow-wave sleep.
The bulk of sleep is stage two.
Now we think stage two has something to do
with memory consolidation,
memory processing.
So important stuff happening we think
in the formation of memories.
The type of sleep that's often ignored
in most conversations is stage one.
People don't care about
stage one, it's light sleep.
In fact, a lot of the apps,
there's a lot of technology companies
that are trying to hack sleep
to increase your slow-wave sleep,
make your sleep even deeper.
Just think of the monetary
value that would occur
if any of these companies
could show up with a device
or a product or a pill that you could take
that'll tell you, hey, if you take this,
you're gonna feel like
you slept eight hours,
but you only need to sleep four.
In four hours you're gonna get
eight hours worth of sleep.
How many of you would try it?
Look at you guys.
How many, raise your hands.
You, you (mumbles), okay.
What if they said your
hair would fall out,
a list of side effects, say I don't care.
(audience laughs)
Boom, I'll take it.
Whatever it is.
It's crazy.
You don't care, sir, right?
Something else could
fall off instead, sir,
you would still do it, apparently.
(audience laughs)
But that's the thing.
And the concept behind that is
the concept of sleep is an inconvenience.
And we want people to think of
sleep not as an inconvenience
but sleep as a cornerstone of your health.
Nutrition, exercise, and sleep.
Sleep is for the brain.
It's not the kidneys that have to sleep,
it's not our lungs that sleep.
It's our brain that has to sleep.
It's a restorative process.
It's the most dangerous
thing the brain can do,
actually, is sleep.
So our earliest sleep scientists said
if sleep has no function,
it's the biggest mistake
evolution ever made.
Let me talk to you about
stage one just a little bit.
You'll watch around the room, look around,
you'll see somebody at some point,
this afternoon after lunch,
head starts to roll and
nod, eyes (mumbles).
(audience laughs)
Boom, head drops.
If you nudge that person,
what's the first thing they say to you?
"I'm awake."
(audience laughs)
"I'm resting my eyes."
That's stage one sleep.
Stage one sleep is characterized
by thinking you're awake
when in fact you're asleep.
(audience laughs)
That is a true thing.
Stage one sleep is characterized
by thinking you're awake
when in fact you're asleep.
Think of the power of that.
You can do anything automatic,
anything overlearned,
in stage one sleep.
You can drive your car in stage one sleep.
You can eat in stage one sleep,
you can have sex in stage one.
You can do all these things.
Anything goes in stage one,
as long as it's automatic behavior.
And this'll happen a
lot with your patients,
you talk with them, you
ask them do you take naps?
And they'll take offense,
no I never take a nap.
Well what do you do after lunch?
Oh, I rest.
I watch TV.
You get a sense of them.
But there's no point in arguing,
just know if somebody's in a light sleep,
they'll think they're awake.
It's part of the
situation that they're in.
And if somebody's got chronic pain,
if somebody's uncomfortable,
any kind of sleep
disorders you can think of,
that fragments or make their sleep choppy,
they go back to stage one,
and they go back and forth,
stage one to the other stages.
So they will tell you things
like I have not slept a wink.
And you've seen them sleeping,
but they'll say I have not slept at all.
Because they did not perceive that sleep.
It's unrefreshing to them.
That's stage one sleep.
REM sleep is kind of
the juicy part of sleep
that we always think
about, we're dreaming.
That dominates the last
third of the night.
As the night goes on, your
dreams get longer and longer,
more vivid and more intense.
How many of you have every told somebody
or heard somebody say to you,
especially at graduation time,
I want you to follow your dreams.
You hear that all the time.
But what do we do to these kids?
We cut off their dreaming time.
The time of sleep that we're cutting off
is the last chunk of the night.
We're not cutting off their stage two
or their slow-wave sleep,
we're cutting off their
early-morning hours.
We just all lost some of
our dreams Sunday morning.
We lost an hour of sleep.
Whose idea was that?
Don't say Benjamin Franklin,
he didn't put it into law.
That's crazy, we lost an hour of sleep.
For daylight savings, this
has actually been measured.
There's a part of the brain
we're gonna discuss in a moment,
circadian systems, that
predict dawn and dusk.
And it's very important to anybody with,
any people born with disabilities
to keep track of their circadian system
and make their sleep predictable to them.
But the brain is trying
to predict dawn and dusk.
So if you normally sleep
eight hours a night,
and you skip sleep completely,
whatever reason, you stay up all night,
will you get 16 hours the next day?
No, your brain won't let you do that.
It'll take about a week to
make up that day of no sleep.
And this you know from when
you did (mumbles) overnight.
Every third night was really horrible.
Every fifth night was
kind of a piece of cake,
wasn't so bad, was less painful.
But it takes about five days to make up
that full night of no sleep.
And that fluctuates among people.
But they measure this in teenagers
that that shift in daylight
savings that we just had,
it takes about five days to
make up that hour of sleep.
But they actually lose
two and a half hours
to make up that one hour of sleep.
'Cause they keep waking up too early,
it takes a little while.
So it's a bad deal.
Dreaming sleep, REM sleep, is when we're,
if you have a sedentary lifestyle,
many of our patients have
sedentary, or many of us,
sedentary lifestyles.
If you have a sedentary lifestyle,
your peak heart rate is
when you're dreaming.
The biggest workout your
body gets is dreaming.
That's your peak heart rate, dreaming.
And this is why we think that
people die in their sleep.
Why people get arrhythmias.
Why should somebody get
a heart attack sleeping
instead of shoveling snow or jogging
or doing something physically exerting?
Sleeping is hard.
Sleeping can be very hard on
the body, dreaming especially.
So that's when you get the arrhythmias,
and that's why it occurs.
If you have people who are
using CPAP for example,
we'll talk about CPAP in a moment,
but the machine, the CPAP,
patients sometimes think,
well I slept with it
in the beginning of the night,
and I took it off later.
I used it enough hours.
They actually take it off
when they need it the most.
Sleep apnea's worse when you're dreaming.
That's when the muscles are most relaxed.
So if I have to pick
somebody a time to use it,
I want you to wake up with it,
more important than
falling asleep with it.
So we want them to use
it all night if they can.
But sleep apnea's worse
when you're dreaming.
That's when you have,
again, your biggest workout.
That's also when nightmares will occur.
This is actually my only
real science slide, I think.
This is a coronal section
through a monkey's brain.
There's the third ventricle.
The optic chiasm.
Our eyes crisscross in
the back of our heads,
I'm sure you all know that.
So in the brain there is
an actual piece of tissue
that measures time.
The biological clock is real,
it's not a hypothetical thing.
And where are you gonna put
a clock in somebody's head,
if you're gonna think about it,
where are you gonna stick a
clock in somebody's brain?
We know what time it is based on light.
So the first point in the
body where both eyes meet,
that's exactly where the clock's located.
The suprachiasmatic
nucleus, the optic chiasm,
suprachiasmatic nucleus,
part of the hypothalamus,
this cluster of neurons
here measures time.
And the clock measures time
based on DNA replication,
and there's a cycle.
And these clock genes actually got
the 2017 Nobel Peace Prize,
Nobel Prize in Medicine, excuse me,
not the Nobel Peace Prize.
The prize in medicine was
for circadian clock genes.
And this is so important.
We have the same genes
pretty much in fruit flies
as there are in humans.
The same molecular system is going on.
But it's something kind
of interesting about this,
if you think about the
importance of sleep.
If you look at the retina,
the retina we learned is polysynaptic.
The rods and cones, all
the synapses in there.
There's an exception, 1%
of the cells in the retina
actually have one function only,
to let the clock know
how much light is around.
So it's a monosynaptic connection
straight from the retina straight
to the clock, right there.
No other processing needed.
Right there.
And this is so important to know
whether it's daylight or nighttime,
'cause some of us are
nocturnal, some are diurnal.
We live in the Bay Area,
and a lot of our lives
are dominated by real estate.
If you're a neuron, where
would you like to live?
Right there.
Best blood supply in the entire brain.
Circle of Willis is right there.
You can stroke out your ability to speak,
you can stroke out the use your right arm.
You can't stroke this out
'cause you have the best blood supply.
What does this mean?
That no matter how impaired
your patient may be,
the ability to reset
their circadian rhythms
probably remains intact.
Even if they have retinopathy,
depending on the type,
you may be able to get
some light into them
and reset their rhythms.
There are these circadian sleep disorders.
Delayed sleep phase I mentioned earlier,
but the more common type we see in people
who have disabilities are the
irregular sleep wake cycle.
People with sleep problems
do what's logical,
do what's reasonable.
The reality is that sleep is a paradox,
and I have a slide to
mention that earlier,
to remind me to tell you that.
If we didn't have to do
it, we wouldn't do it.
The more logical you are,
the more analytical you are
in your approach to your sleep,
the more likely you are to screw it up.
Because sleeping is counterintuitive.
Logic, if I can't sleep, I should rest.
That's not how it works.
Logic is if I had a bad night
of sleep, I should sleep in.
That's not how it really works.
Because that's thinking of sleep
as only the amount of sleep.
And I told you those four components,
amount, quality, timing, state of mind.
We gotta work with all
four of those components
when we try to correct somebody's sleep.
So variable wake up times
is what we're seeing a lot.
A lot of irregular times.
Especially people who are kind of,
don't have great social interactions
or being fed on a continuous system,
they may have some of these,
missing these social cues.
But we can work with these systems
and get people to sleep better.
The nice thing about sleep
problems, even if we only get
the patient to sleep a little bit better,
makes a big difference to the family.
When kids can't sleep, when
an adult has trouble sleeping,
I've seen this in people with
Alzheimer's, for example,
if that person has trouble
sleeping poorly at night,
that's when they get institutionalized,
that's when it becomes an issue.
So always take a moment
to ask your patients,
what's your motivation to go to bed,
what's your motivation to get out of bed?
What are you doing this for?
Do you wanna go to sleep?
You gotta start thinking
about, you get to go to sleep.
Not that you have to go to
sleep, but you get to do it,
it's actually a really cool thing to do.
If you provide yourself with a nice, safe,
comfortable place to
sleep, you get to do it.
You can regulate anybody's sleep rhythm
by regulating these four variables.
Social interactions,
exercise, light, and food.
You can take a wild rat.
A rat is a nocturnal animal,
genetically nocturnal.
By the way, we'll talk
about melatonin later.
Melatonin in our brains elevated at night,
it means get ready for sleeping.
Rats have elevated melatonin
in their brains at night also.
Melatonin to them
signals them to get busy.
Night's coming, it's time to get busy.
So melatonin's a signal
that night's approaching.
You take a nocturnal animal like a rat,
all its family's nocturnal,
it's meant to be nocturnal.
You take that animal and put it in a cage,
and pretty much only give it
food when the lights are on,
and when it's dark, you
don't provide any food.
When the lights are on, you
provide it with food again.
What will the animal do?
Initially the animal will go hungry.
It's not supposed to be
eating when it's daytime,
it could be attacked, it's scared.
But eventually that animal will change.
You can make a nocturnal animal
behave like a diurnal animal
by changing the timing of its meals.
Which also teaches us
something for our patients.
You know, some of your patients,
you know, you come in,
how many of you have
seen patients come in,
you try to talk to your
patients about their tendencies,
the genetic tendencies, and
the kids look at their parents
and think that they're screwed
because looking at their
parents, they're like, no.
I tell them all the time,
your tendencies are not your destiny.
Just because your
parents are a certain way
does not mean you have
to be that way, right?
You can be different.
Your tendencies are not your destiny.
So you can change a pattern
of behavior of an animal.
Somebody says, I'm just a night owl,
and then the parents,
oh, I'm a night owl, too,
and his dad's a night owl,
so that's just the way it's gonna be
and he can't go to school,
he has to be home-schooled.
That's not really true, right?
It's just a little bit harder for you
to become a day person.
So you can regulate timing of meal.
A lot of young people,
a teenager will tell
you they're going to bed
at, say, two o'clock in
the morning or something.
I assure you their last
meal is not at 6:00 p.m.
They're eating very late into the night.
You can say, hey, you
wanna stay up all you like,
but there's no food after seven,
there's food in the morning,
you're gonna start waking up.
You're gonna start getting up to go.
You need a reason to do this.
So social interactions,
exercise, light, and food.
We can talk about melatonin
and how to provide melatonin to children.
The melatonin receptors
are turned off by light.
So if you have blasting
light in somebody's face,
you can be eating pounds of melatonin
and it won't really do much for you.
Because the receptors aren't expecting it.
It's not there for it.
So it has to do with timing of light also.
You wanna give people light
first thing in the morning.
So I talked to you about
motivation earlier,
and I talked to you about light just now.
One of the things that I'll do
sometimes with younger people
is, they wanna do video
games and stuff like that.
I say, why don't you do video games
first thing in the morning?
They say I don't have enough time.
I say you do if you get up earlier.
You can get up earlier.
One of the things I like
with all my patients,
my adult patients especially,
a very frequent question
I'll ask an adult patient
is what do you do for fun?
They're usually surprised
by that question.
I don't know if you ask that routinely,
that's a routine question
for me to ask a patient.
What do you do for fun?
Patients will brighten up and
tell you all kinds of things.
I had a lady that was depressed
and her husband had died.
She'd had a stroke,
and now she was staying at
one of her siblings' house.
And they all go to bed at eight o'clock
because they get up early to work,
so she has to go to her room early.
And I said, what do you do for fun?
She goes, well when I was
younger, before I had my stroke,
she used to work in a tomato cannery,
tomato cannery, and she
had the night shift,
she used to work through the
night in the tomato cannery.
And she used to sing during her shift.
And now she can't sing
because it's gonna disturb the family.
So we had this lady start
singing mariachi music
in the clinic full blast,
it was kind of wonderful to hear her
just brighten up and change.
But you'll be surprised
when you ask a patient,
what do you do for fun?
Once you get a sense of
what they do for fun,
if a patient says I do nothing for fun,
then you gotta think about
depression and things like that.
Because of course,
depression often travels
with sleep problems.
It's unusual to find somebody
who's truly depressed
who does not have sleep problems.
But if you ask somebody,
what do you do for fun,
then I ask them whatever
it is they say they do,
can you do it first thing in the morning?
I wanna play guitar, I wanna work on this,
whatever they say.
Do it first thing in the morning.
And if you don't do it in the morning,
you can't do it till the next day.
I want you to have a reason
to get up, a motivation.
All of you, when you work up this morning,
couldn't you have stayed
in bed a little bit longer?
Why did you get up when
you got out of bed?
Because you had to.
In your head you had to come here today.
Thank you for coming today.
But you always in your own
head is, I had to, right?
Waking up is one thing, getting out of bed
is something different.
Waking up is biological.
Getting out of bed is volitional.
You don't really have to
get out of bed, right?
But you should.
(audience laughs)
But waking up is one
thing, getting out of bed
is something different.
So if you control these four variables,
you can get anybody to
change their schedule.
Also when sometimes your
stuck getting a history,
trying to figure out what to do,
if you remember this mnemonic, SELF,
you can use it to get your history.
Go through these four variables,
social interactions,
exercise, light, and food.
And the reason I use SELF is
because you can self-correct.
You can empower the
teenager, the young adult,
whoever's having these sleep issues.
So you can fix this,
this is a fixable thing.
So think about these four
things when you talk with them.
Social interactions,
exercise, light, and food.
Let's talk about hypnotics,
we got 10 minutes left.
I'm sure we can cover
hypnotics in 10 minutes.
This is a recent paper,
Oliviero Bruni from Italy,
so you guys can pull this.
Some of you probably
subscribe to this journal,
but you can grab it, it's a recent paper.
And it looked at the sea of
things we can try for insomnia.
First off, there's nothing
approved in the US or Europe
to treat insomnia in children.
Anything you do is obviously
gonna be off-label.
First time treatment is behavioral,
and that's a lot of what I do.
When I first started,
we did a lot of meds.
Now almost everything we
do is behavioral first.
And how you do it is a separate question.
The most widely prescribed
substances are antihistamines.
Most widely recommended things,
but not a lot of evidence that they work.
It's unusual these days
to have anybody show up at your clinic
who's not tried melatonin
before they came to see you,
because it's over-the-counter,
it's widely used,
and how they use it and the
timing of it is interesting.
But it's thought to be a
safe choice for most people.
There's data with children with
autistic spectrum disorder,
pretty much any disability
you can think of,
childhood disability you can think of,
may have tried melatonin at some level.
And it works for some people.
Also, by the way, sleep is super sensitive
to placebo effect.
I'm not saying these are placebo effect.
Sleep is super sensitive
to placebo effect.
Because your state of mind
influences how you sleep.
And you can prove this.
Open up any PDR and look
at the package insert
of any sleep aid.
And you're gonna see
that when they did the randomized trials,
the placebo group always has listed
a certain percentage of hangover.
Why does somebody get a
hangover on a placebo?
Because they think they
got the active agent,
they slept longer than before,
and now they've waken up fuzzy
'cause they've overslept.
So sleep is super sensitive
to the placebo effects.
And that's also why things
stop working after a while.
Benzodiazepines, they
don't recommend using them.
These are the older benzodiazepines
that you're familiar with.
I have a second slide on this.
A few studies on zolpidem,
zaleplon, eszopiclone.
I lean more to using these medications
'cause I have more experience
with them with adults,
so I use them a lot with kids
if I'm gonna use anything.
Clonidine, often talked about,
many of you will use
clonidine in your patients.
It's popular in child psychiatry circles.
You may inherit patients with it.
But again, not a ton of data with it.
They did not like tricyclic
antidepressants in this one.
The tricyclic antidepressant
that I will sometimes use
with success is doxepin,
that's the generic name.
It has a brand name which we won't say
at a lower dose you can try,
and I've done that with some kids.
And you can also get the
generic, it comes in 10s,
you can chop it in half
and get a five out of it.
You can do that.
But they don't recommend using it.
Trazodone and mirtazapine,
which has another brand name
many of you guys know,
require more studies.
But that's just from this study here.
And I can discuss these
in more detail with you,
but let's give you an overview of these.
But the real issue is not
the pill, it's the insomnia.
That's the issue here.
Parents say what are
you gonna give my kid?
Oh, why do I need to give him anything?
Why can't the kid sleep?
Is it the kid can't sleep,
or the kid can't sleep
when you want the kid to sleep?
What are we talking about?
What is the situation here?
What's the timing here?
The thought of sleeping
will wake people up.
That's when you know
somebody's become habituated
to having insomnia.
If somebody says to you that
they're drowsy, they're sleepy,
they're in the living
room, they're watching TV,
and they're fighting sleep,
they get to the bedroom
and suddenly wide awake.
The thought of sleeping is waking them up.
You become habituated to being awake.
You can only voluntarily
keep yourself awake,
you can't voluntarily force
yourself to fall sleep.
If I were to look at anybody's
respiratory rate here,
and say somebody's breathing at,
let's say 12 breaths a minute,
if I say take 12 breaths
in a minute, I'll time you,
you'd screw it up.
You can't do it.
It's an automatic thing.
Once you try to do it,
you can voluntarily keep yourself awake,
but you can't voluntarily
force yourself to fall asleep.
It doesn't work that way.
On top of this, what's often overlooked
are the circadian principles.
Peak alertness for humans,
and this applies to children and adults,
is about two hours before you fall asleep.
You're most awake before you fall asleep.
You have to be.
If sleeping is really the most
dangerous thing we can do,
and if you think of
sleep in that framework,
that sleeping is inherently dangerous,
you must be able to protect
yourself while you're sleeping.
Think of it that way.
Then it makes sense that, biologically,
we have a surge of alertness
before we fall asleep.
You'll notice yourself,
if sleep was just a linear
thing like gasoline,
you'd be most awake first
thing in the morning.
But you're not.
You're grabbing coffee.
You have more alertness mid-morning,
you have a drop in
alertness in the afternoon,
and then without catching any nap at all,
you feel more awake in the evening.
When you feel that slump this afternoon,
you're gonna blame it on your lunch.
But oddly, breakfast
doesn't make you sleepy,
and neither does dinner.
Why does lunch make you sleepy?
It's not the food.
It's the time of the day.
Our predators are less likely to attack us
when the day's at its hottest.
So we get that surge
of alertness at night.
That's why it's so hard
to go to bed early.
If you had to think about
what's easier for you,
for most of us it's
easier to push away sleep
than to advance sleep.
So you wanna regulate somebody's sleep
and help somebody sleep better,
any of your patients
you're taking care of,
ask the patient, ask the family,
what sleep schedule
would you like to have?
Whatever numbers they
pick, they say things,
I want to go to bed at 10, get up at six.
Okay, from now on, you
get half your wish today.
You get up at six no matter what today.
But you're gonna go to bed a midnight.
I can't stay up that late.
Yes you can, you have insomnia,
you can stay up later.
You have to remind them, okay?
(audience laughs)
Remind them they have insomnia, okay?
But what you're gonna do by that is
it's gonna crunch their sleep.
You're gonna make their
sleep more efficient.
And that's what we talk about.
Sleep efficiency to us
refers to time of sleep
divided by the time in bed.
You wanna be efficient in your sleep.
Little kids are 90% or so efficient.
Actually, something I
should've mentioned here,
and I wanna go backwards just briefly
in my time that I have left.
There's something missing in this slide.
I gotta fix this slide a little more.
Nobody sleeps eight hours in a row.
You never have and you never will.
Human sleep cycle's about 90 minutes.
Newborn's about 60 minutes.
About every hour, all
humans open their eyes,
make sure everything's
okay, and go back to sleep.
All of us wake up at night.
You have to.
If you didn't wake up, you'd
be easy pickings for predators.
Lions and tigers would pick us off
at three o'clock in the morning.
Waking up is normal.
We have to wake up.
Watch anybody sleep.
By the way, you've got a
great sleep center here.
My wife is a sleep doctor
at UCSF, Dr. Kin Yuen,
she works with Dr. David Claman,
I'll put in that plug, that's
allowed under the rules?
Thank you.
And you also have Dr. Gwynne Church
who's fantastic and trained
with us at Stanford.
So you've got some really
good people up here.
But if you visit their sleep lab,
I'm sure you're welcome
to visit the sleep lab,
you'll see that nobody
sleeps through the night.
Look at the tracings.
People wake up all the time.
We have to.
And about 10 times per hour
we get little bursts of brain waves
that feel like we're awake,
that look like we're awake,
little about three second
bursts of brain waves.
It's just not long enough
for you to remember it
and be aware of it.
But we all wake up during the night.
We have to.
And this explains sometimes
how people are behaving
in their sleep.
So back to this issue of the hypnotics.
This is a little bit skewed on here,
but there was a recent
study came out of Canada,
and it looked at the quality
of over-the-counter melatonin.
In many countries, melatonin
is a prescription item.
I think in Australia and Europe
it's a prescription item.
But in Canada and in the
US, it's over-the-counter.
And what I learned was,
if you try to sell
something over the counter,
you wanna give it a long shelf life.
'Cause when you look at the bottles,
you wanna know what are you gonna get.
They reviewed the quality of
the melatonin over the counter
and they found what was
labeled on the bottle
and what was inside the bottle
fluctuated by over 400%.
Over 400% fluctuation.
Even within the same brand
it was fluctuating over 400%.
And about 25% of the
samples had serotonin,
because melatonin breaks
down into serotonin.
So you may be giving some
of your patients (mumbles)
and also giving them melatonin,
you may be giving them an
extra boost of serotonin.
Just know that,
that the quality of
over-the-counter melatonin
is not that good.
So in Canada, the pediatrics people there
are actually importing
the melatonin from Europe,
and they're talking about
regulating melatonin.
So they may create a black
market in Canada, maybe,
where they're gonna start importing
or sneaking across the
border US melatonin,
because it's gonna be
controlled over there.
So there's gonna be a flip side to this.
But just keep and eye and know
what happens with melatonin.
There are some brands of melatonin
that seem to have better quality control,
at least they market themselves that way.
In this survey, the melatonin types
that had the worst variability,
they were all bad in this study,
the worst ones were the ones
that came in as a gummi.
Anything that was in a gummi
type was very unpredictable
how it would work.
And we tend to like these
gummi stuff in kids, right?
I like taking a gummi vitamin myself.
And if it also was marketed
as having a combination.
Sometimes you'll see
melatonin with some valerian
or some chamomile or
some hops or magnesium.
The things that were in combination,
they tended to be also widely fluctuating
what was on the bottle
versus what was actually on the label.
So don't lose sleep over that, ha ha.
(chuckles)
Another thing I like to tell people is
don't equate sedation with normal sleep.
We can sedate kids a lot.
We can give kids alcohol.
You can get black out drunk.
Do you have a good night
of sleep the next day,
do you wake up feeling good the next day?
No.
Just because you're sedating somebody
does not mean you gave
them a good night's sleep.
A lot of things that
we're doing to our kids
is sedating them.
So keep that in mind.
We're running out of time.
I wanna make one last point to you
about this paradoxical reaction.
If we have a surge of alertness at night,
you have a child with disabilities,
and you give them something
that sedates them,
what's gonna happen is
you're gonna dissociate,
you're gonna start having
intrusion of awake behavior
into sleep behavior.
And when this happens,
the kids will freak out,
they'll start hallucinating.
So sometimes this paradoxical reaction
is simply the wrong dose of
medication at too high a dose.
I've got 18 seconds.
Oh, I've got two minutes, good.
The timer says 14 seconds.
So let me make a point here.
When you prescribe something to a child,
or an adult with a disability,
you cannot assume the
parents are gonna give them
what you gave them, what you prescribed.
Parents are gonna wonder, oh
this thing might be too strong.
Parents are gonna feel guilty
about giving the kids
medication for their sleep.
So they'll underdose them.
They'll give them half the
pill to see what happens.
And they wanna give it early
'cause they don't want the kid
to have a hangover the next day.
So now you're underdosing somebody
and giving the pill too early.
When the brain expects to be awake,
your underdosing disinhibited them,
they'll start to hallucinate.
They'll have intrusion of things.
If I have one cocktail,
I think I'm charming.
If I have five cocktails, I'm asleep.
So that's what happening, right?
You disinhibit these people,
and they start to freak out.
So these paradoxical reactions
that you may document
or be aware of, go carefully
over what they actually did.
You may find the parents gave
less than the recommended amount,
and also gave it earlier than expected to.
If you wanna prescribe for real,
make them go to bed later,
that way you have the homeostatic drive
working in your favor.
Go to bed later, and go up on the dose.
The kids have healthy
livers for the most part.
They metabolize the medication faster.
So you can actually go higher on the dose
if you're gonna bother at all.
If you're gonna prescribe at all,
go higher than you expect to.
Don't go low,
you're gonna have these weird
reactions in these kids.
I saw many times when I was
a child neurology resident,
they would give us chlorohydrates
to sedate the kids for procedures,
and the kids would flip out
because we underdosed them
at the wrong time.
Just a couple of things on sleep apnea.
Sleep apnea is a real thing.
You're gonna see it all over the place.
The thing to watch for
in our group of kids,
and our adults especially,
you don't have to be
overweight to have sleep apnea,
but what you are gonna
have is a high-arch palate.
Look in their mouths and
see if the roof of the mouth
is narrower than the
width of their tongue.
If they stick out their tongue
and you can see little
crescent marks of the teeth
along the edges, they
probably have sleep apnea.
The tongue is gonna be
too wide in their mouths.
Down Syndrome is an obvious
example of that (mumbles).
So you see this high roof of the mouth.
Because kids when they don't sleep well
have trouble behaving,
the first thing that happens
when you don't get enough sleep
is you have trouble paying attention.
In the DSM IV, I know we're
not in the DSM IV anymore,
but this was the book
that some of you are using
as doorstops in your office now.
(audience laughs)
Okay?
That book says specifically
for attention deficit disorder
that they had physical features
such as high-arched palates.
Which I'm telling you is a
physical finding for sleep apnea.
So there's not doubt that
there's some people out there,
probably college students now,
were diagnosed as ADD as kids,
actually had sleep disorders.
By the way, CPAP has never been better.
When we look back on our field,
we're gonna see this as
the golden era of CPAP.
It's just never been
better than it is now.
The machines are quieter,
smaller, lighter.
They have pocket-sized CPAP machines now.
Pocket-sized CPAP machines are available.
It's gotten a lot, lot better.
Just because somebody
couldn't use it before
doesn't mean you should try it now,
'cause it's just gotten a lot better.
This is my last point I
was gonna make to you.
These are our conclusions.
Thank you so much for listening, guys.
(audience applauds)